[Music]
is this reality well we're experiencing
something right now so maybe the better
question is what is reality could
everything we see everything we
experience everything that exists in our
entire universe be artificial supporters
of simulation theory believe that not
only is it possible that we're living in
a simulation it's likely and the more we
look for evidence the more we find let's
find out why
the idea of the universe being a
simulation is not a new one theories
exist in ancient cultures around the
world modern simulation theory comes
from nick bostrom a philosopher at
oxford who wrote an influential paper on
the subject in 2003 assuming that living
in a simulation is possible bostrom
presents the simulation trilemma which
says one of the following must be true
one we destroy ourselves before we're
able to create a simulation two we're
able to create a simulation but choose
not to or three we are definitely in a
simulation boston believes each of these
is equally likely to be true now i don't
think that's controversial we use
computer models to study the human
population predict the weather for
entertainment we simulate everything and
when a civilization can create a
realistic simulation the most obvious
one to create is that of its own early
existence bostrom calls this an
ancestral simulation and a civilization
that can do this wouldn't just create
one simulation it would create many and
those simulated civilizations might
create their own simulations of the
universe and on and on like russian
nesting dolls of reality now you're a
character in that world and you think
you have free will and say i want to
invent a computer so you do
hey i want to create a world in my
computer
and then that world creates a world in
its computer
and then you have simulations all the
way down when elon musk was asked what
he thought the chances were that our
reality is the original base reality the
odds that we're in base reality is one
in billions
neil degrasse tyson is a little more
conservative he thinks the odds that we
are in base reality versus a simulated
reality is 50 50. a 50 50 chance that
everything we experience is artificial
that's still pretty high and even though
we mostly hear what scientists think
about this it's not scientific theory
simulation theory isn't math it's
philosophy it isn't physics it's
metaphysics so what we need is hard
evidence that we live in a simulation
and to find proof
all you have to do is look
[Music]
let's start at the beginning there was
no space or time the contents of the
entire universe were concentrated to the
size of a tennis ball and had a
temperature of a quadrillion degrees
then suddenly the big bang everything
explodes outward faster than the speed
of light then about 14 billion years
later we've got galaxies and planets and
ice cream and k-pop
[Music]
yeah i could do without the k-pop me too
okay if before the big bang there was no
space and no time
what was there what about the beginning
of the universe from the religious point
of view god created everything fine
where was he before what caused the big
bang to happen in the first place what
made god decide to snap his fingers or
wiggle his nose or whatever he did to
make everything happen if you ask a
physicist to explain what existed before
the universe they'll give you an answer
about quantum foam dark energy or
something just as bonkers as the big
bang ask a theologian what existed
before god created the universe and
you'll get an answer equally as
confusing but what does make sense is
that the universe was just sitting there
dormant then someone somewhere decided
to boot up a program and in that program
our program or all the laws of the
universe
electromagnetism and gravitational force
are written into the program the speed
of light gets a value there's code for
planck's constants of mass speed and
time avogadro's number is in there along
with a bunch of other rules that govern
the behavior of everything that exists
all part of our program even
consciousness itself is part of our
simulation if you've never heard of
simulation theory then this might sound
far-fetched but some of the world's most
respected scientists technologists and
philosophers believe that it is more
likely than not that we are living in an
artificial reality
so
how do we prove it
[Music]
if we live in an artificial reality it
would make sense for there to be
occasional glitches philip k dick is one
of the most influential science fiction
writers of all time movies based on his
books include blade runner total recall
minority report the adjustment bureau
and plenty of others he believed there
are many universes and sometimes those
other realities bleed into ours he
claimed to have visions of this and even
wrote stories like the man in the high
castle based on these visions
that in fact plural realities did exist
superimposed onto one another by so many
film transparencies one way other
realities blend into ours could be the
mandela effect the mandela effect is
when a large number of people have
memories of events that don't match
reality this is called the mandela
effect because millions of people
specifically remember nelson mandela
died in prison he didn't people remember
his wife walking beside his casket in a
funeral procession that was on
television for two hours that day this
never happened or the berenstain bears
which people insist were always called
the berenstein bears people remember the
tycoon from monopoly having a monocle
that he never had what was darth vader
famous for saying luke i am your father
nope he never said that what what about
stouffer's stovetop stuffing best part
of thanksgiving no it isn't because
there's no such product stovetop is made
by craft ah no
the evil queen from snow white who
looked into her mirror and said mirror
mirror on the wall
nope
magic mirror on the wall
who is the fairest one of all
my reality is shattered people remember
febreze being spelled with two e's
people remember jiffy peanut butter but
there's no such thing and there are a
lot more a lot more personally i don't
have most of these false memories but
there are a few that get me the
flintstones there are two t's in the
flintstones i remember just one and what
about the fruit of the loom logo i could
swear it looks like this
but it doesn't this is the actual logo
no cornucopia coin you what now basket
didn't you say basket for crying out
loud and at the end of moonraker a
terrible but excellent james bond movie
i remember jaw's girlfriend as having
braces i mean i specifically remember it
she didn't have braces
i just can't get my brain to accept it
that's the mandela effect so why do
millions of people distinctly remember
different things glitch in the
simulation yep
philip k dick also felt when we
experienced deja vu is because something
in our simulated universe changed and a
new timeline branched off of the current
one we are living in a
computer-programmed reality
and the only clue we have to it is when
some variable is changed ever feel like
you've lived a moment before that's
because according to philip k dick and
others you have deja vu is the
simulation correcting itself with new
information but skeptics can easily
dismiss these theories the human mind is
terribly unreliable they don't accept
this as evidence but we're not done yet
[Music]
we live in a huge universe 200 billion
trillion stars and even if life is rare
you'd think there'd be some evidence of
it somewhere this is fermi's paradox but
according to the drake equation there
should be over a million technologically
advanced civilizations just in our
galaxy and on average the nearest one
should be just a few hundred light years
away but there's nothing at least not
that we can see so where is everybody
are we really alone in the universe or
does our program only focus on us and
what about the physical rules that are
in place max tegmark a cosmologist at
mit said the strict laws of physics
point to the possibility of a simulation
putting a cap on the speed of light sure
is a good way to keep your sims from
venturing out too far from home
theoretical physicist james gates
thought simulation theory was crazy then
he started studying quarks and electrons
he found error correcting code buried
deep inside the equations used to
describe string theory so you're saying
as you dig deeper
you
find computer code
writ
in the fabric of the cosmos
into the equations that we want to use
to describe the cosmos yes
computer code computer code strings of
bits of ones and zeros
dr gates has changed his mind about
simulation theory in 2017 a group of
scientists at the university of
washington proved they can embed
computer code into strands of dna
everything in nature is math look at the
fibonacci sequence you get the fibonacci
sequence by adding two previous numbers
in the sequence together so one plus one
equals two two plus one equals three
three plus two equals five five plus
three equals eight and so on forever you
get the golden ratio also called fee by
dividing two consecutive fibonacci
numbers so the number 89 is a fibonacci
number the next number in the sequence
after 89 is 144. 144 divided by 89 is
the golden ratio it's about 1.618 we see
fibonacci numbers and the golden ratio
everywhere the number of petals on a
flower is usually a fibonacci number
lilies have three petals buttercups have
five chicory has 21 and a daisy has 34
and the spacing of each petal is
arranged in a circle according to the
golden ratio as trees grow the number of
branches they form is a fibonacci number
and not just plants animals too the
ratio of female to male honeybees in a
colony is the golden ratio 1.618 the
human body conforms to the golden ratio
too most of the body follows the numbers
one two three and five one nose two eyes
three limb segments five fingers five
toes the proportions of the body like
the length of your shoulder to your
elbow and from your elbow to your
fingertips that's the golden ratio even
a dna molecule measures 34 angstroms
long by 21 angstroms wide fibonacci
numbers and the golden ratio from the
spiral of seashells to the spiral of a
galaxy and everything in between
fibonacci numbers are everywhere now
some claim this is a coincidence that
humans look for patterns in chaos
because that's what we're programmed to
do what what program to do
it isn't that interesting by trying to
debunk simulation theory they actually
end up proving it no matter what we
study whether it's something the size of
a galaxy or as small as an electron
everything in the universe seems to
follow patterns and rules in other words
a program
[Music]
to simulate an entire universe you'd
obviously need more advanced technology
than we have but that doesn't mean we
won't get there moore's law says that
computing power doubles every 18 months
and this is held true for about 50 years
now that is slowing down a little bit
but only because of physical limitations
assuming we can learn to make microchips
smaller and there's no doubt that we
will it's predicted that artificial
intelligence could surpass human
intelligence within the next hundred
years as elon musk points out when he
was a kid the world's most advanced
video game was pong two rectangles on a
screen
forty years later video game technology
is barely distinguishable from reality
he said that six years ago and even in
that short time video game engines have
become even more realistic look at this
footage from unreal engine 5
when a world we can build feels as real
as our own
imagine what games are going to look
like in the next six years or the next
60 or the next 6 000
but simulating an entire universe how
big of a computer would we need well
it's estimated that there are 10 to the
power of 80 atoms in the universe let me
put that on the screen just for fun
okay but that's a lot if each particle
needs 128 bits to calculate its position
and momentum you're at 10 to the power
of 83 bits and that's just for data
storage we also need computing power to
track what each of those particles is
doing if we say two floating point
operations per second or two flaps per
particle we're at 2 times 10 to the 80th
power flops there aren't even words for
these numbers and this is the computing
power for just the stuff in the universe
what about human intelligence the human
brain can perform 100 trillion
calculations per second or 100 teraflops
multiplied by billions of people the
numbers are ridiculous to power all of
this the simulation would need access to
multiple dyson spheres the
megastructures that capture 100 of the
energy of a star or the simulation would
have to harness the energy from black
holes this is why famous physicists like
dr michio kaku are not on board with
simulation theory he claims that
simulating a universe is not
scientifically possible the only
computer capable of simulating a
universe is the universe itself now at
first glance this makes sense but with
all due respect to dr kaku
that's not how simulations work when
you're playing a 3d video game the
entire game world isn't rendered instead
the game engine only calculates what the
player can see and interact with at that
specific moment if we were living in a
simulation then it would make sense that
the creators of the simulation would use
a similar technique and wouldn't it be
interesting if there was evidence that
this is exactly what happens well wait a
minute do we have proof
sweet fancy moses
supporters of simulation theory often
point to video games as a way to explain
if not prove that our reality is
artificial in a video game the only data
that is rendered is what the player sees
or interacts with if you're playing a
video game and there's a car or building
a mile away that entire object isn't
rendered the game engine only renders
the bare minimum of information to make
the object look real a distant building
is rendered as just a few pixels not
that complicated as you get closer the
engine renders more details but still
it's just a facade the engine doesn't
bother calculating what's inside the
building to actually go in the game
engine always knows how much data to
send you and doesn't bother with
anything else if we live in a simulation
it would make sense that our reality is
rendered the same way and we could test
this wait what do you mean we can test
this specifically we can use the double
slit experiment here's how it goes if we
fire particles in a straight line at a
screen after passing through a single
slit we would expect to see this
clumping pattern on the screen
if we try this with a wave we expect to
see a pattern like this where particles
are most dense in the middle of the
screen but radiate outward similar to
the clumping pattern when we add a
second slit it starts to get fun when
the waves pass through the double slit
each slit creates its own wave when
those waves intersect they cancel each
other out that creates a pattern like
this it's called an interference pattern
so particles passing through two slits
create clumping patterns waves through
two slits creates an interference
pattern make sense
good
if we fire electrons through the slit we
see the clumping pattern as expected an
electron has mass so it's a tiny bit of
matter so if we fire electrons through
two slits we should see two clumps but
we don't we see the wave interference
pattern this shouldn't be happening
what's going on here for years
scientists assume that the electrons
were colliding with each other causing
the wave pattern but in the 60s the
experiment was modified so that only one
electron at a time was fired through the
slits there was no way the electrons
could interact with each other yet we
still see an interference pattern
scientists wanted to see what was
causing this so they added a detector to
observe electrons as they pass through
the slits that's when things go from
weird to paranormal as soon as the
detectors were installed the
interference pattern went away and the
clumping pattern returned take the
detectors away and the wave interference
pattern is back
but that's a different result to what we
had earlier
so here's the last bit of sneakiness
that we can play with atoms surely now
you know we're we're going to get to
grips with it
leave the detector there
but just very quietly go
and unplug it
don't let the atoms know that you're not
spying on them
run the experiment again
now if you can explain this using common
sense and logic
do let me know
because there's a nobel prize for you
it's as if the particles are aware
they're being observed then physicist
john wheeler had an idea he called it
the delayed choice experiment how it
works is photons are projected through
the double slit but the detector is not
activated until after they pass through
the slit but before they impact the
screen photons were emitted as waves
passed through the slits as waves but
when the waves were observed before
hitting the screen they suddenly behave
like particles again
still don't think there's an
intelligence at work well what wheeler's
experiment showed is that even though
the electrons started as waves but
behaved like particles after being
observed at the moment the decision to
observe them was made the electrons
recorded themselves as having passed
through the slits as particles the
electrons change their state by going
back in time
[Music]
i personally find that i gravitate more
towards the information theoretic point
of view and and believing that
uh that i'm i the universe that i exist
in is a very good high quality
simulation now this experiment is
happening on a table in a lab a very
short distance so what happens when we
observe light coming from vast distances
like say a galaxy 100 million light
years away if light from a distant
galaxy is projected through the double
slit it creates the wave interference
pattern but if we push those photons
through a measuring apparatus to observe
them the wave again collapses all the
way back to its source
this is called retrocausality simply by
choosing to observe the photons this way
they reach back through time 100 million
years and alter their state on the other
side of the galaxy but like a video game
engine it only does this if we're
looking even though our universe is full
of galaxies those galaxies may not
actually be there if we're living in a
simulation then stars and galaxies could
simply be projections and only when we
get up close with those projections
become more detailed this is an
excellent way to save computational
resources and because we're stuck with a
hard limit of the speed of light getting
to far-off places is really difficult
limiting the speed of light is a useful
rule to have in place quantum mechanics
like the double slit experiment and
quantum entanglement only makes sense if
there's a program at work because only
the program can ignore the laws of
physics and ignore the concept of time
itself
[Music]
a convenient case for simulation theory
is you can't disprove it the big bang
that was the simulation booting up we
haven't found aliens they're not in the
simulation how come ufos seem to violate
the laws of physics well because they're
programs operated by the simulation
creators they don't have to follow the
laws of physics
but who created the simulation well
that's the big question isn't it when
you think of the simulation creator as
an omniscient intelligence who exists
outside of our understanding of space
and time it sounds an awful lot like
you're describing god and just like you
can't prove we're not in a simulation
you can't prove there is no god if
something miraculous happens or
something horrible happens you can say
it's part of the simulation just as
easily as you can say it's part of god's
plan something i find very interesting
is that many believers of simulation
theory are fierce atheists they dismiss
the idea of god as corny superstition
there are plenty of devoutly religious
people who dismiss provable science like
evolution and the age of the earth
people on the religious side say that if
there is no god and life is just a
simulation then nothing matters without
god to guide us and sometimes punish us
depending on what you believe our
actions don't have consequences
i disagree even if we don't live in base
reality we still live in our reality and
our actions here do have consequences as
for what happens after we die simulation
or not nobody really knows both sides
argue that faith and science are not
compatible
isn't this hypocritical whether you
believe in god or you believe in
simulation theory the real question is
what's the difference
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment share all that
stuff really helps a small channel
trying to solve the youtube algorithm is
like trying to find proofer in a
simulation but with your help we'll get
to the truth until next time be safe be
kind and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you